foreign they gather at the entrance of
Rajai Shah prison to chant and scream at
the regime
the clerics in charge have executed four
protesters and this group fear several
more will be hanged Behind These Walls
the mother of one begs for mercy
then the police turn up and social media
posts suggest they opened fire dissent
in Iran is a reasonable offense
no wonder thousands have fled seeking
sanctuary in unfamiliar places
arrived in England on an inflatable boat
but she has found peace and Security in
a community in the Northeast
members of her family however are in
serious trouble
because
her nephews Farzad and Farhad have been
arrested by the police for Waging War
against God a charge that's punishable
by Death
Atomic sticks
[Applause]
myself
frustrated by the economy and the people
who run it the pair took to the streets
as large anti-government protests swept
through their hometown of snow
a few days later the regime came looking
for them
is
this video was shot when their mother
Charla was told that both men had been
charged with offenses punishable by
death
farzad's son sits on her knee
[Music]
why can't you hear me God I'm burning
inside she cries
how did you feel when you saw
the video that your sister appears in
pleading for her son's life
libertarian
language
krushank has spent 18 months in Britain
awaiting a decision on her claim for
Asylum an uncertain Journey for her and
her newborn son but there's one thing
she's sure of as a woman's rights
activist she can't go back to Iran
did you make the right decision coming
to the UK
there is a price to pay for challenging
the Islamic Republic
here the father of a 22 year old
protester says goodbye his son Mohammed
Medi karami was executed last week by
the mullers and their immovable regime
John Sparks Sky News
[Music]